opposers I am fed up I'm sick of people
saying I don't love immigrants just
because I voted for Trump support the
wall and want fewer immigrants it's
total slander I just want to protect our
border and our values so I always keep
my eye on immigrants first story daca
it's not just your child's first word
it's also a socialist Obama policy that
lets so-called dreamers stay in America
if they were brought here illegally as
kids kids they can't even be old right
now the left would have you think Donald
Trump doesn't care about dreamers just
because he reversed the order to protect
them because they've never heard the
expression if you love something let it
get deported if it comes back ask how
the hell it got through a border
security just listen to how much Trump
cares you know we tried to get it moved
quickly because we'd like to help duck I
think everybody in this room wants to
help with daca yeah exactly yes
Trump would love to fix the daca problem
that's why he created the daca problem
and sure he could just unilaterally
restore the policy but Trump's too
unselfish for that he wants everybody
involved
he gave dreamers a seat at the
bargaining table right in the middle of
it where the chips go and who wouldn't
want to be a bargaining chip getting
tossed around and traded for a border
wall in huge cuts to illegal immigration
that's fine but look guys like me and
Trump we're not heartless help I'm
pretty sure Trump's heart is larger than
average bulging with goodwill and
whatever they put in a filet-o-fish
he wants dreamers to be protected that's
why he keeps calling out Democrats for
their laziness demanding that they do
something to address daca Trump's like
the compassionate bank robber who takes
a hostage and the demands that Chuck
Schumer released that same hostage
some victimless crime everybody wins the
dreamers are safely in deportation limbo
and good news
Trump always wins at limbo there's never
been a bar he wasn't able to break right
through dreamers I'm on you moving on
next up I got to talk about a hot topic
I don't mean where I get my best
offspring t-shirts they're good I'm
talking about chain migration it's like
chain smoking only dangerous here's how
it works
legal immigrants come to our country and
they drag their parents and siblings
along with them
these people are sucking on the teats of
their relatives green cards to get that
sweet sweet permanent resident juice
that's gross
and I'm not the only one who's talking
about it chain migration chain migration
chain migration chain migration is a
total disaster
it's a huge disaster like a tornado of
female Ghostbusters big President Trump
is thankfully taking a stand because
this issue hits close to home
which home the White House what is the
immigration status of the first lady's
parents Victor and Amalia knobs are
legal permanent residents are now close
to obtaining their citizenship and it's
really likely that Melania sponsored her
parents which she can do under lead for
it America's family reunification policy
or as Trump likes to call it chain
migration oh you love this so much
cuisines
you you you human bookmark Oh actually
you've only read this far suck at Hayes
you've got Trump being some kind of
hypocrite ball he's not publicly
denouncing chain migration while his
family benefits from it he's kindly
making sure that no one with immigrant
in-laws ever has to spend time with them
again it's brilliant
everyone knows in-laws are the worst I
mean have you seen Everybody Loves
Raymond if you have and there's a
relevant example from it please let me
know until then we must continue to
denounce chain migration for the sanity
of every new immigrant and because Trump
shouldn't have to spend another
Thanksgiving explaining why he likes his
turkey burnt and covered in ketchup che
migrators I'm on you keep moving
finally I've got to talk about words
I've been using these sentence chunks
for years but no the less kombucha has
gone flat just because a few words got
removed the agency in charge of US
Immigration Services updating its
mission statement and removing the
phrase nation of immigrants the director
of the US Citizenship and Immigration
Services saying that the revised
statement now emphasizes protecting
American workers and safeguarding the
homeland yes protect American workers
safeguard the homeland defend the
American workers working on homeland
give it a chance
it only had one bad season come on
the left fix this language update is an
attack on the very fabric of who we are
as a nation denying that immigrants are
woven into our national DNA but as we
all know DNA was a myth invented by
ancestry.com look libs
a willingness to remove and add things
as we grow and change as a country is
what makes America unique this new
language has just arrived on the shores
of this mission statement to make a
better life for everyone who reads it
and we need to be open to this influx of
new phrases new innovations to create a
melting pot of ideas from all over the
world like keeping all the immigrants
out it's a great idea because like I
said I love immigrants that's why I'm
keeping my eye on them
[Music]